What's good, my well read ballas?!
This week we gonna holla, holla holla! with
Horton Hears a Who, by Dr. Seuss.
It’s BALLS hot up in da jungle where our
main man Horton the elephant be straight chillin.
When outta nowhere- brutha start hearin’
some shit like somebody talkin to him.
“Da f***?
Alls he see is a speck of dust!”
Turns out, he ain’t high as s***.
This speck got a small-a** dude livin’ all
up on it.
Fo real!
Bein the righteous balla he is, Horton put
da spec on a clover to keep it safe- cuz no
matter how big o’ small people be, they
still people! S’all good ‘til some punk
kangaroo hops by wit her hater-ass baby.
They both start talkin smack to Horton sayin
“Psh.
I don’t see or hear no people on this clover.
You musta lost yo godd*mn mind.”
Then- SPLASH.
They jump in the pool and almost wreck dat
spec right then and there.
Horton all “ Oh Hell NO!
I gotz to protect my peeps” so he snatch
up dat clover, and hightail it to a safer spot.
Then dude start hearin’ dat same voice from
before.
This time it sayin’ there be a HOOD called
Who-ville on dat spec, and it’s full of
righteous bruthas n’ sistas called Whos!
The Mayor all like: “Yo Horton.
Mad props fo’ watchin our back like dat
man.
You bout as real as they come, playa.”
When word get round dat Horton carryin’
around a flower and conversatin’ wit it
n’ s***, a bunch of monkeys start messin
with him and boost the clover!
They ain’t buyin dat da spec got people
livin’ on it, so they give the clover to
a nasty ol’ eagle, who drops it in the middle
of a field so Horton won’t find it.
Ain’t dat some s***?
Horton chases after the eagle an’ combs
through three MILLION clovers ‘til he finally
finds the one wit his peoples on it.
Horton ask dem Whos how they holdin up?
The mayor like: “Man not so good.
Dat fall f***ed us up BAD.”
Just then, dem kangaroos and monkeys roll
back to the scene, only this time wit a POSSE
in tow!
They tell Horton dat he stirring up s***,
so they gonna throw him in a cage while they
cook up his clover!
Not knowin how to prove to the haters that
his peoples exist, He tell the mayor of Who-ville:
“Yo, y’all best holla’ as loud as you
can so they KNOW I ain’t fakin’” But
the mob can’t hear fo’ s***.
So the Whos take it up a notch.
They straight raise the ROOF; clangin’ pots
an’ bangin’ tunes to make themselves heard,
but it ain’t cuttin it!
Now Horton is buggin!
So he ask the mayor if anybody holdin out.
Turns out- there’s one dude wastin’ everyone’s
time wit a damn yo-yo!
So da mayor get this young blood to haul ass
up a tower an’ give a live-saving hollar!”
HOLLAAAAAAAAA!
The little thug lets out a “Yopp!”, an’
BOOOOOOM!
The mob hear every-thang! Horton say: “See!
I wasn’t jivin’ you!
These tiny people are fo-real!”
The kangaroo says: “Damn, son.
You was right!”
Afta dat, all da animal homies come together
and swear to protect da Whos.
Errybody in da hood know Doc Seuss fo’ his
mad skillz at writin kids books.
But you might NOT know that he also got cred
fo’ writin’ political cartoons during
WW2.
So there ain’t no doubt Seuss got da war
and its victims on on his mind when writin’
bout how important it is to protect ERRYBODY-
no matter who they be:
“A person's a person, no matter how small!
And you very small persons will not have to
die.
If you make yourselves heard!
So come on, now, and TRY!”
Matta’ fact, this book dropped right afta’
dat s*** storm ended and countries started
pickin’ up the pieces- specially Japan.
Some say Horton representing how America was
super chill bout helpin Japan build their
s*** back up afta’ da war left em busted.
Da whos reppin the Japanese, whereas dem hater @ss
animals actin like dem relentless peeps who
wanted REVENGE against da Japanese.
And when you faced with people who wanna do
you like dat, ERRY VOICE – even the tiniest
ones – got the power to make a difference.
It’s only when EVERY Who got off their a**es
and hollered that da hood got saved.
No matta’ how small you feel, you got legit
power when you band together with yo homies.
Ain’t no doubt standin up fo yo beliefs
is rough, but doing it alone take a special
set of balls.
Horton just ONE hustla tryin to convince a
whole BAND of jabronis that Whos are LEGIT.
They even throw his a** behind bars, but Horton
keep it 100 and sticks by his principles.
And thats whats it mean to have REAL balls, man.
Lord knows there still plenty of little folk
out there who need help, and it ain’t always
easy to do right by em.
But you CAN’T let the haters keep you down,
cuz no matter how bunk yo situation be, you got a voice,
and it matters.
So neva’ back down on yo values
and make yo’self HEARD!
Ya heard? Yo, thanks for stoppin by my library.
See y’all next time, Playas! Peace!